No,
yeah,
you can say things to people like tell,
tell the truth and be good,
and those are.
Those are cliches obviously,
and so they lack power because they're
cliches,
but you can take them apart and utilize
them in a manner that stops being a
cliche and you do that by being more
humble about them.
I would say,
because maybe you can't tell the truth
because you don't know what the truth
is,
but one thing you can do is you can
start saying things that you know to be
untrue and you might say,
well,
how do I know that they're untrue?
And the answer to that is,
well,
you need a whole philosophy of truth.
The elaboration of an entire philosophy
of truth to answer that question and so
we're not going to bother answering that
question because in some sense at the
moment it's beside the point that isn't
the issue.
The issue is there are times in your
life where you know that the thing that
you're saying is not true.
It's a deception.
It's a lie of some sort and you're using
it to manipulate yourself or another
person or the world and you're also
possessed,
fully possessed of the idea that you can
get away with it and there's a satanic
arrogance about that.
If in fact that is the archetype of
arrogance that's portrayed in the
mythological character of Satan because
Satan is precisely the archetype of the
element of the mind that believes that
it can twist and and banned the
structure reality without paying the
price for that and you can't imagine
anything that's more arrogant than not
because really do you really think that
you can twist the structure of a reality
and that that's going to work out for
you without it snapping back.
It's so obvious that that can't work,
that,
that everyone knows it.
But anyways,
back to the initial point is that you
know by by the rules of the game that
you yourself are playing.
That some of the Times you're violating
the rules of the game that you're
playing.
And the first issue with regards to say,
stating the truth or behaving in a
responsible manner would be merely
stopped cheating.
At whatever game it is that you've
chosen to play,
that's a good start and that'll
straightened.
That'll straighten out your life.
It'll start district.
Start to straighten out your life and so
well the flood.
What?
How does the flood tie into this?
Well,
you know,
we live in a corrupt structure were
corrupt as individuals.
We live in a corrupt structure and part
of that corruption is just happenstance.
It's the way things fall apart,
but the other part of it is that not
only are we not aiming up,
we're actually aiming down and the flood
story is a warning and it's a very clear
warning and the warning is if you aim
down enough and then if enough of you
aim down at the same time,
everything will degenerate into
something that's
indistinguishable from the chaos from
which things emerged at the beginning of
time.
It's something like that because that
the cosmos that's presented in
mythological representations is chaos
versus order,
right?
The order is on top,
you might say,
in the chaos is always underneath and
the chaos can break through or the order
can crumble and you can fall into the
chaos and that chaos is intermingled,
intermingled potential,
and the way that you destroy the order
and let the chaos rise back up,
which is exactly how it's portrayed in
the flood story is by well by inhabiting
the corpse of your father.
That's one mythological motif and
feeding on the remains and with no
gratitude and no attempt to replenish
what it is that you're taking from and
the warning and the flood story is don't
do that for very long because things
will happen that are so awful you cannot
possibly imagine it and that'll happen
to you personally.
It will happen to your family and it'll
happen to your community and it's
happened to people over and over
throughout history and it is quite
interesting.
You know it's.
It's very soon after the story of Cain
and Abel.
When you see evil enter the world in the
story of Adam and Eve,
along with self consciousness and evil,
there is the the ability.
That's the knowledge of good and evil.
That's the ability to hurt other people,
self-consciously,
to know what you're doing,
and then of course instantly cane takes
that to the absolute extreme and he uses
that capacity to to destroy really what
he loves best.
He,
he gets as close as a human being can to
destroying the divine ideal because of
course his brother Abel and Abel is
favored by God and and destroys them.
Which cane tells God at the end of that
episode that his punishment is more than
he can bear.
And I think the reason for that is where
are you?
Once you destroy your own ideal,
what's left for you?
There's nowhere to go.
There's no APP,
and when there is no APP,
there's a lot of down and you know
there's an idea that was put forth very
nicely in Milton's paradise lost when he
was describing from a psychological
perspective.
Essentially what hell is hell is your
inhale to the degree that you're distant
from the good,
that that might be a good way of
thinking about it,
and if you destroy your own ideal,
which you do with jealousy and
resentment and the desire to pull down
people who you would like to be,
let's say,
then you end up in a situation that's
indistinguishable from hell and and the
way the story,
the biblical story unfolds as well.
It's it's Cain and then it's the flood
and so kane adopts this motive being
that's antithetical to being itself,
at least a positive being itself.
He does it voluntarily.
He does it knowing full well what he's
doing and the net consequence of this
that as it ripples through the entire
social structure is that God stands back
and says,
this whole thing has got so bad.
The only thing we can do is wipe it to
the ground and that is.
That is no joke.
That's exactly how things work.
And one of the things that's
extraordinarily terrifying about that
sequence of stories,
and I believe this to be true.
I think I realized this independently of
any of the analysis that I was doing a
mythological stories because I looked at
what happened in places like the Soviet
Union and in Mao's China and in Nazi
Germany and the most penetrating
observers of those societies.
The people who are most interested in
how it was that those absolute
catastrophes came about.
All said the same thing.
It was rooted in the degeneration of the
individuals who made up the society.
You know,
you hear well,
people will fraught were following
orders.
It's like,
no,
that,
that explanation doesn't hold water or
that you'd be punished if you resisted.
While there was some truth in that,
but nowhere near as much as people might
think.
Especially at the beginning of the
process more.
It was that people decided each and
every one of them to turn a blind eye to
the catastrophes and to participate in
the lies and that worked the entire
societies.
And they went,
as you know,
they,
they veered their way downward to
something as closely approximating hell
as you could hope to manage.
Especially in places like Nazi Germany.
And while I in all three of those
places,
and in Maoist,
China and the Soviet Union,
and so the thing that's so frightening
about one of the things that's so
frightening about the stories in genesis
is they say something very clear,
which is that your moral degeneration
contributes in no small way to the
degeneration of the entire cosmos.
And you say,
well,
I would like my life to be meaningful.
People say that really would you really?
You really would like your life to be
meaningful.
You think maybe people would trade a
little nihilism to not have to face that
particular realization.
And I think people do that all the time.
It's a terrible wait to,
to,
to realize,
but we are networked together and that
that's the price of.
Or let's say that's the vulnerability
that's associated with our intense
capacity to communicate.
And it is certainly possible that the
ripples of our individual actions have
consequences that are far beyond the
limits of our immediate consciousness.
And I also think people know that too.
They know that in the way that people
know things when they don't want to know
them,
which means they know them,
embodied,
they can feel them,
they can sense them,
they have an emotional response to them,
but there's no damn way they're going to
let them become articulate because they
don't want to know and when you're
feeling guilty and ashamed about the
things you've done or not done,
and I know that can get out of hand as
well.
It's often because there is a crooked
little part of you that's aiming at the
worst possible outcome.
You know,
one of the things you said about the
shadow,
you know that young's famous idea that
everyone has a dark side and that that
dark side needs to be incorporated and
made conscious.
Young said that to the shadow of the
human being,
reaches all the way to hell and he
actually.
That's the thing that's so interesting
about interesting about reading Carl
Young,
is he actually means what he says.
It's not a metaphor.
It's like the,
the,
the part of you that's twisted against
being is aligned with the part of the
cosmos.
Let's say the conscious cosmos that's
aiming at making everything as terrible
as it can possibly be and you know it's
a terrible shock to realize that.
It's partly why people don't realize
that it's something that people keep at
an arm's length.
It's the same as recognizing yourself as
a Nazi concentration camp camp guard,
which is a very useful exercise because
there's absolutely no reason why you
couldn't have been or still could be one
so and if you think otherwise,
then all the more reason for assuming
that you would be unable to resist the
temptation if it wasn't in fact offered
to you.
And if you don't think it's a
temptation,
then the then there's so much that you
don't know about human beings that
you're not even in the game.
Because if it wasn't a temptation,
then people bloody well wouldn't have
done it.
And plenty of people did it.
And it's no wonder.